hello and welcome to see your playing
martyr bollocks from the UK and most
cases i will play 93 LH three line again
and let's see so shooting for some nope
for some a 6b five stuff not to this
time hmm okay maybe just g3 kicking back
later f5 is not possible here and Bishop
e2 will probably send the night back
home wow
so we wants to go Bishop g5 yeah you can
go Knight f3 just back or go H 1 H was
also a decent move I'm taking this why
not yeah it's a night on g7 and the
bishop on f6 you should be hits the
other way around so night down okay yeah
I can just go before you send them back
so yeah so h5 I guess man doesn't look
too bad and now H 698 you can definitely
just play for the attack but I mean this
is not bad either just kill kill off f5
and play this position a night will come
to g3 and it's a more or less technical
win
it doesn't need to be technical but I
just play it like that idea of this move
is to play Bishop situ to a form would
be quite quite nice to trade that
LightSquared bishop now that would help
me to get more control over f5 and enter
on the light squares on the queenside
wind here white has all the time not
going to rush things here and the
slightest
got this book as well now everything is
one the queenside and what a doll trying
to test about prema here or maybe
yeah I'm taking stuff is good and greed
is good at least sometimes check check
check lame now you played that age 6
move and basically that lost the game
just the blunder I mean okay the
position is it's already pretty good for
white here this is not exactly exercise
a success and legs while the successful
Kings Indian but of course you don't
need to play age 6 I expected him to
play age 5 stopping h5 after which yeah
the King side is pretty safe and white
can now advance him you know so it's
pretty nice but okay no way as near nice
estimate after age 60 to age 5 you
cannot open up the edge file or play
this after which why just has this
automatic automatic win almost yeah it's
a it's a tricky line to face this age 3
but it doesn't have to be with that bad
of course okay well thanks for watching